[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast my
name's Russell Leeds and on this week's
show we're gonna be looking at some
exclusive insights that Samuel never
talked about before his childhood and
some challenges that he's facing right
now is something I doing bro yeah man
awesome question for you I want to start
with you became successful in property
at 17 and I know if I'd say it depends
on they're gone gone well okay you
started in property at 17 yes
and then that sounds like to anyone sort
of listening unbelievably young low most
people think what they're doing is 17
they're smoking in a bush out change
their mates how did that come about well
my L wasn't successful at 17 I bought my
first house of 17 I guess how you define
success I would say most people would
define a 17 year old buying a property
as a success how did it come about um
Wow
firstly I got the I got the information
on how to do it
secondly I was naive enough to actually
believe that it was possible do you know
I mean that I do not you mean because
when you're older you become more
cynical and then around about 2008 2009
which is when I got started you could
buy houses and refinance them the same
day like everyone was buy so people were
buying hundreds of houses back then mmm
just hundreds basically the bank would
just finance thing everything and I
thought well I can do that the only
thing that was stopping me was the fact
that I couldn't get mortgage so do you
think that like today it's a lot more
difficult to get started as a 17 year
old as it was back when used eyes no
because now I think there's other things
that you can know I think it's just
different I think now you can do light
now for instance you can do rent to
rents
mm-hmm and you can do deal packaging and
joint ventures and like I think it's
just different talking about what you
mean by being naive I know I kind of
know what you mean but you mean you were
so naive that actually words in your
favor yes quite explain I think that
people say that if you are you know you
don't know what you're doing because
you've not lived you're not experienced
but in one sense that's an advantage
because you're gonna be foolish enough
to give it a go and when you give things
a go sometimes they happen
and if you're prepared to do whatever it
takes and keep going eventually will
work so and people you know people say
oh it's just a dream it's a pipe dream
what does a pipe dream mean surely every
entrepreneur has to start with a dream
so how can I use dream in net that's a
good thing
start with a dream a naive stupid
unrealistic dream turn that into a goal
turn that into a business plan and then
take action yeah that makes a lot of
sense so what was your dream then
so in seventeen what Wendy when did the
dream happen when you were 16 I can't
remember the exact only funny one okay
so how so when I was 17 the dream saw
what happened and it depends what you
mean by the dream so I always felt like
I wanted to be significant
I wanted to empower people went to I'd
like something in my in my belly that
burned where I didn't want to live like
a normal average life mm-hm so I guess
in one sense that's the dream I then
thought property could be a good vehicle
I have to read in Rich Dad Poor Dad by
Robert Kiyosaki and the dreams and then
and then I went to a property event and
I went to a property event and I met
Simon Zoosh a stepdad I slept at Tim he
was also getting into property and he
was looking at countenance he
backgrounds and mouse and I want to
start doing properties and he was
refinancing he's a personal asked about
properties and I just thought oh I'll on
this and I just really really badly
wanted a house I think so the dream for
me to begin with was just to get a house
I want to buy a half a house I want to
be a homeowner at the moment I'm just a
kid and and all my friends are thinking
about getting a car all my friends are
thinking about you know who they're
gonna go on a next date with I want a
house I want to own a house and I want
to rent and I want to be alone well that
was what my that was a dream yeah that
was my first dream and then when I did
that then I thought right now I want
more so my dream was to get a house and
I did it at 17 years old and the funny
thing is is that I always knew that was
gonna have to be 18 to buy a house
because you can't buy a house unless
you're 18 so I was when I was 17 I had
the dream and I was thinking when I'm 18
him when I'm 18 when I'm 18
and then a mortgage broker told me that
you've got to be 21 to get buy to let
mortgage so suddenly I'm like oh man and
I've spent all my life savings on going
on property courses and stuff and
something I thought oh man for years
like suddenly it felt like a lifetime
away but then when when I realized that
I could actually do it when I'm 18 by
putting it in someone else's name I
thought well holy cow
I've only what I maintain I can do it
now yeah it went from a bad thing into
something that was actually really
liberating it was it was like a week or
two before my 18th birthday just
interesting those that like so something
happened that hit you back
but then finding the loophole was
actually better than if you don't
why two weeks better I suppose but
that's away in the first place yeah but
it's turning about into a good it's
flipping the cards yeah which is what
you mean you constantly do yeah you
mentioned as well that you put your life
saving I mean not many 17 year olds I
have life savings yeah so how did that
come about because we were talking about
this the other day weren't we yeah oh
well oh wait yeah we were all successful
people that I know now yourself James
Caan whenever I see him to interview
someone already bagram someone certainly
in the UK when they were a kid they all
had paper M's and they all played
Monopoly yeah it seems to me just I'm
not saying if you didn't play Monopoly
as a kid or have a paper and you do just
think you're screwed no more no more
opportunity but if you did play Monopoly
and you did have a playground you're
probably gonna be super successful
unless someone steals you dream so I had
papers man we both did we didn't used to
used to like you know you were the kid I
remember at school who would like buy
magic tricks from from dad from his
market still free market stall but
getting right at the wholesale price
yeah and then learn the trick go to
school
yeah show people the trick and then sell
it down for like the r RP and mate you
know make a pretty decent play the
profit that my dad would made when he
was selling yet people what I'll be
doing that while I was at school in the
breaks of stuff and they thought I was
saying drugs
manager thought also drugs because we
both found an account at Bradford &
Bingley didn't work yep there's little
savings account we used to take our
paper money and stuff which to iron my
money I stopped I in it look at it smell
it a bit that's a bit weird and then
take it to the bank I didn't used to
dost why why why I am it and then take
it to the bank I'll make it I just
wanted it in my hands crisp and nice and
clean to look at it to respect it
because if you disrespect money we're
hanging around very long the first time
we did it we worried about burning a
hole in it no can you imagine no that
never happened so then you how much
money you have saved so when I left
school at 6 just over six grand
but that wasn't just some paper round's
it wasn't just for magic tricks it was
also from I mean ok I kind of as an
entrepreneur as a teenage school
entrepreneur slowly advanced so I
started off washing cars and cutting
lawns we did that though when we were
like 10 yeah but I didn't go hard into
into wanting to make money in iron my
name is I was 14 but yeah we did I can
remember like when we like going that's
people's I remember stories now back
then I thought they were nuts but now I
look back and I don't know why so I'd go
knock on the door I'd say I would like
the car washed you know 5 pounds they'd
be like tell you what I'll give you a
pound just to wash the wheel hubs and I
was like suck but they were just giving
me because for you is easy so much but
they just wanted you off their back they
didn't want you to scratch the car hit
eju and they gave you a pound basically
yeah
we spent a Saturday is doing that didn't
we got washing cars I remember ruining
someone's lawn come on they're there I
mean when you ruin that lon and every
time we'd walk back from the school we
have to walk past the house and you'd be
like looking at the floor walking really
fast oh they didn't recognise me but you
were trying you're having a bash and I
think so so I went from washing cars and
cutting lawns we even cut in moms lon
because we didn't really get we didn't
get pocket managing it but we had to
work for money right so one of the cool
things that we had as well is we used to
have to buy our own clothes we start all
that sort of stuff yeah we we started
buying we need stuff to do jobs to earn
I know I didn't used to buy clothes I
used to get Hameed
from Tamara from you or uncle Gareth or
whoever and then the money that I had
that had worked for my clothes lounge
like yeah save cuz I was really bothered
I want until you have more money than
Mei saved sorry I was really bothered
about having designer clothes like that
but you you one of the things that I
always remember about you and obviously
growing up was you did not give a crap
what anyone thought about you whether it
be a teacher whether it be a any other
kids at school you fret no one you
didn't care how did you fit that served
you in business and in poverty and life
because it's the same today oh you
definitely the same today for sure when
things are you know I I know about
anyone that around you knows about you
why why is that
okay the definition of integrity is
doing what you would do in private is
the same as what you do in public I am
Who I am and I'm the same everywhere I
mean within reason of course sometimes
there's contexts and things like that
but generally speaking I am I am just
completely you an and I don't mind what
people think about me I don't know why
as you said I was like it when I was a
kid I just cuz I cuz I cuz I Know Who I
am and I love Who I am and if someone
else doesn't like me maybe they're valid
reasons to not like me maybe on the
prick you know at times but if someone
doesn't like me at least I Know Who I am
and I'm content in Who I am she just
doesn't bother me and I think actually
in business you need to be like that so
I think it's certainly really one sees
about that but I don't know anyone out I
mean there's always people to a degree
everyone always says you know I you know
I don't give an F or whatever I always
speak when anyone says that it's because
they do if anyone ever makes a big deal
of it because they care yeah but a lot
of people you know they know we
shouldn't care people think but I don't
know anyone I was talking about this a
few a few of us went went for a business
meeting
you came up in conversation and we were
saying you know we all think we don't
really care people think about us
but compared to Samuel we do yeah it's
weird
tell me how you think it's served in
business because it's strange most
people care what other people think yeah
and it's not like you have other people
feel so if I I mean this has happened
you know I've said something you've been
a little bit a little bit offended and I
care about that I care that I've
offended somebody because I don't want
to be the cause of anyone's pain okay so
I do care
I'm not level you know if I say
something if I'm sharp with Amanda my
wife and she's she's upset about it oh
she's hurt
I care I care about what I don't care is
you don't care look you're stupid you
don't care you don't care
standing out from the crowd you don't
care people thinking that you're
ignorant or no that's all been
misunderstood or people say no so how's
it served me because I guess specially
when you're when you're in business if
you've got lots of tenants and you've
got lots of stairs of trained students
and you've got lots of customers and
lots of people that are seen you put an
EQ video I think a lot of people that
see videos the bigger you grow the more
opinions are gonna happen hmm
and if you get offended or if you care
really badly or you can't sleep because
someone doesn't like you and you're
never gonna please everybody 100 percent
at the time ever it's funny because the
same sometimes like I've got a property
at the moment in moment was HMO that
properties are the same tenants in the
same group for about four and a half
years and pretty much the same people
paying the same rent
same story rents have gone up a lot in
the last four years in Birmingham AL ah
so some of them are paying like 20 30 40
percent less than what they should be
paying however the property because
they've been living there for ages
because the property's got general wear
and tear the carpets are a bit mucky the
kitchen probably needs changing stuff
other so I decided that what we would do
is we would spend ten thousand pounds
refurbishing the house we'll get a new
kitchen new bathroom new carpets paint
it and really go to town on it in fact
even like moving the morning round but
then what we do is we put the rents up a
little bit and and we talk we know we
told all the tenants hey everybody this
is what we're doing we can only add in
very to the house lifting up it's gonna
be beautiful and the rents going up a
little bit but the rents will still
below the average price okay so it's
going a little bit some of the tenants
well I thank you so much we really
appreciate you looking after the house
of course we're happy to pay a little
bit more
and thank you for refurbishing and
openness a long time and some of them
were furious and saying how dare you put
the rents up no I don't want you to a
new kitchen I like it the way it is I'm
really annoyed so the same thing same
news yeah some people think is brilliant
and some people think it's awful the
same people in the same house with the
same situation some people think I'm
horrible I are terrible how dare he do
that I don't want to I don't want a new
kitchen and then other people are
Wow thank you you didn't have to do that
so I'm not thinking that's a small
example but on a much bigger scale when
you're a businessman and when you're an
impactor and an influencer you're gonna
have some people that are really upset
with you
and I think if I if you lose sleep over
it you just need to think is what I'm
doing reasonable is what I'm doing fair
am i doing it am i doing this we've good
a good heart and good in town you know
is it ethical legal moral and I'm a jerk
I'm a generally trying to help people
add value and dance all those things yes
yes yes yes yes then I think it served
me not wasting time and energy over
people being upset with me because some
people just like you want to broke my
leg and I was in Africa dying lost 25%
of my blood and the doctors had just
told me you won't walk ever again bad
place mmm lying in my own you're in
because the nurses you know it's
different not eaten for days because
they said no unless you've got family
but bad place
people are mocking me online in the UK
people are saying oh I bet it's a
marketing stunt like I don't even
gentleman so I think that it's early
well because some people we really
crushed by that there was there was some
people would think they'd be really
offended oh no way dad yeah yeah and
then he would eat the market then they
become bitter mmm you know so I think
that's that's why it served me as an
influencer as well which I am now in the
property in the property space I say if
you can't take the heat get out the
kitchen so I think you have served me
yeah
you also mentioned belief you know MIT
being being naive and one of the things
that again a lot of people say about you
people
no you and me as well to be fair but
they say you've got like an unbelievable
belief in you in yourself in what you do
in you very confident gonna succeed no
matter what the circumstance is and then
you mentioned that you warm its pop
because you were naive enough to believe
it do you think believing that you can
do something is plays a major role 80%
of the way there how much of a role do
you think you know I think he plays a
massive role who was it was it Steve
Jobs you said people Henry Ford
everything him before if you think you
can you can't you up but no no no it got
even better quote Steve Jobs he said the
people that are crazy enough to believe
that they can change the world are
usually the ones that actually do and I
think that's such a powerful quote
because it is crazy thing I genuinely
believe that with the philanthropy work
and the education and the and the
inspiration and the videos that we put
out that I genuinely believe that it's
changing the world
I believe that when I leave this world
don't leave it a better place now that
perfect I make mistakes but but I
genuinely believe that and some people
might say oh that's ridiculous you're
not making the world a better place
there's seven billion people but I
believe that and I think having an
absolute faith and belief and here's
what I think I think if if something's
possible then I can do it that that's
very much how I live my life so if
someone's done something before then I
can do it too as long as I'm a pair to
put in the work that way and and and and
follow the steps and get the training
and put in the wealth the persistence
and the hard work so and it's a bit like
you know the amount of the four-minute
mile hmm the foreman who was it that
broke the four-minute mile Roger someone
or just someone what what your banister
anyone yeah yeah I think he was he was
when he broke the four-minute mile what
happened was very quickly and then it
been years everyone stopped everyone all
you can't you can't that's it if you if
you ran a mile in less than four minutes
you'd physically die
it is impossible the human body cannot
do that and that's what that was what he
was just you can't
and then when roger bannister broke the
four-minute mile what happened was
suddenly lots of people did it that can
only be belief can only be belief so I'm
not doing things I'm not breaking
records unfortunately I'm not a record
breaker as far as I'm aware but what I
do do is I find people here are way more
successful than me and I say well look
I'm gonna stand on the shoulder of
giants if they've done it it's possible
mm-hmm so what did they do they must
know something I don't I'm gonna learn
that and then I'll go to town and make
it happen how much would you think is
possible for everyone then because I
believe it is a very interesting book
called bounce which talks about it's the
myth of tongues in our society with very
much program to believe oh it's because
they're just naturally good at that it's
very much look at the draw of you've got
it we haven't and I don't believe that
to be the case I believe that there is a
degree of natural talent but as pretty
much is all down to anyone can pretty
much do anything they want to do is all
down to hard work dedication
how would you arguments though with
successful entrepreneurs who disagree
make no you born an entrepreneur no yeah
you're that way I don't think that what
tell me your opinion on that okay so I
think it's complex I don't think it's
black or white if I said I want to be
the tallest man in the world
unfortunately I'm born six-foot I can't
be 7-foot if I said I want to be you
know the best the best basketball player
because of certain physical I think
there are some things that you can't
necessarily you're not tall enough to be
a good basketball player right right I'm
making myself feel really short now
six-foot but but so so they almost yeah
so then there's some things or if I say
I wanna be a supermodel
well yes oh there's something mighty you
talking about we were saying this thing
about Lou Welsh gaunt that tell us that
about being badly Walsh yes so Louie
Walsh
of course if
signing someone to be an artist a pop
star they need to be attractive yeah but
Luke was signs people that we're simon
cowell but like but they're ugly and
Louie says no no one's really ugly
anyone can scrub up and look pretty
decent if you slim and you do you hair
right and your Omega by your fashionable
unless you're born absolutely
atrociously or you know and I'm not
meaning to be cool or anything qui
unless you're born with like really
severe problems
appearance-wise you can scrub up and
look good so I guess you've got even
even even from an appearance point of
view if you make an effort and you
really want to be good-looking and you
think I'm not good-looking
you can probably be good-looking yeah
that's true so okay so my disclaimer is
there are exceptions you can't push down
through grey yeah but I think that yeah
I think that you can you can be whatever
you want cuz this I know it talks about
this in bounce there's a lot of people
where they say right my kid is going to
be a champion chess player yeah and then
they are and there's villages where all
the tennis champions are from the same
village
yeah it's not that they're just born
tennis champions it's just that they
happen to have played loads table tennis
that was but yeah I tear up the right
table tennis so I think you can and I
also think it's a much more sometimes
you have to forget what's true and you
have to say what serves me better what's
going to empower me better and to say
I'm just born how I'm born and I'm good
at what I'm good at it takes me all the
power yeah it's much better to say you
know what I can be whatever I want to be
I just need to practice this is a
mistaken responsibility yeah by saying
on naturally someone say live a day in
all seriousness they were fat because
their mom smoked when they were a baby
it's just ridiculous
pushing away responsibilities on July
you know pushing it on but that's what
people do right now people take a little
time I'm born this way I don't believe
listen you cannot snooze I'm born this
way there's an excuse for anything you
can do you want to how do you want to be
cuz you have a choice listen I mean I'm
not judging anyone if you're happy how
you are then great but don't moan and
say it's because I was born that way
no you know what about I don't if you've
heard the story of the guy
two guys in fact who grew up together
one guy was really successful really
rich really happy really nice happy
family loving husband the other guy was
a loser bum beat his wife no money and
mean to be these guys and I said to the
bad guy why are you such a bum why do
you beat your wife why you're an
alcoholic why because my dad's that way
alright fine then they asked the other
guy why are you so successful unhappy
and and and you know rich and living I
was because my dad was a bum he beat my
mom I don't want to be that way same
situation same circumstances but they
both had a choice
so I'm generally speaking and of course
there's exceptions and things can happen
but generally speaking I think that life
is 90% what you make it and 10% how you
take it
hmm I agree how much that of that 10% do
you think is what you attract how do you
mean so for example you say ten percent
is what mbers it's what happens to you
but not in percent of it is how you
react to that no yeah okay go on explain
light your life yeah your life right now
yeah your business everything has
happened to you who you are as a person
is 90 percent how how you've created
that you've made that so what's the 10
percent the 10 percent is how you react
to things that aren't in your that's
what I'm saying right see if you can hit
my car and you break your legs
mm-hmm and you're you end up in the
hospital in right
that can't happen and it can be oh my
goodness now to say oh it's your fault
you got to take responsibility you got
hit by car it's your fault well maybe it
is maybe there's my question is right I
wasn't saying what you were saying ten
percent right is what happens to you and
the 90 percent is how you react to that
and how you can how your your mind says
there's no other way around temper says
what happens to unite up sense how you
react yeah but but you still have a
choice on how you respond to the 10
percent of course yes yes but how what
my question is is like law of attraction
all that's teachers yeah
the ten percent you have control over as
well because you attract the things that
the
how you don't have 100% control in your
life so you think about ten percents
fair you have 90% control okay okay this
is very confusing but we get I get the
overall point hopefully the listeners
will be able to understand both of us
and we just want to explain it in a way
it will both understand I think I
understand you I think better it's fine
it's fun let's just move on from that
well okay we both agree you take
responsibility for your life you create
your own life you create your own brand
I don't say so it's funny because even
if I even make decisions about stuff
like do I want to be a person who swears
he said do you swear no no no do you
want to be a person that swears maybe
you do maybe you want to swear maybe you
want to be someone that swears just
occasionally for emphasis let me know
what you have to control over that don't
just say oh it's just who I am
others around people that swear so I
swear I'm just born this way don't born
that way yeah I could say I'm just born
I I hit people I punch people in the
face that annoy me I'm born that way no
no be another one take responsibility
you have the embalmer you won't be born
wanting to do that but take control and
and and live your life how you want to
live you create the person that you are
so what we are there any things then
that you've got going on in your life
that you want but maybe you don't want
bad enough to actually make it happen or
you want to take control of it having be
able to I think my biggest of the areas
of life so you've got spiritual you've
got relationships you've got
recreational interests hobbies yep fun
you got business finance of all the
things the thing that I have struggled
with that I haven't quite got to grips
with and knowingly is my is my health
I'm you know and and and that is that
it's probably for I think it is I think
it's a good thing because I think me not
being quite as healthy as I want and not
being and and struggling a little bit
because you know and I'm about to give
excuses I'm not gonna do that because
I'm born that way man I'm born
overweight no no excu environment is my
right no but I think it probably gives
me more
thie for people that struggle with their
wealth and finance this so I think if I
had a ripped six-pack oh my goodness I
would have it all
get your humble you know so having a
slight weakness I mean like oh man I
struggle with this why can't I get it
together
then when I'm talking on I'm coaching
people who are saying oh man I'm
struggling my finances why can I get you
it forces me to have a little more
empathy otherwise it'd be very easy for
me to just be like oh look at me I'm
perfect yeah man I'm perfect I've got it
together I've got whereas I'm like I can
win so it helps me relate to people that
are struggling a little bit more so I'm
turning a bad into a good here when
really I should just get ripped mate
don't ask me because then I'm gonna have
to commit to it are you to get ripped
I'm gonna get richer I'm gonna impact
more people and we're gonna get ripped I
don't know ask me ask me next year
you'll say the same thing lot of effort
big sacrifice everything so everything's
a sacrifice but it's always worth it in
the long run if it's important to you I
mean as people say to me all the time
they say Tammy I've got an idea I'll
teach you how to get ripped and you
teach me how to get wealthy and we can
just do you know fair trade I'm thinking
in principle that sounds awesome but the
here's the deal think how much do you
charge per hour one on one to teach
someone how to get healthy 100 pound an
hour well I chose 10 grand for an hour
one-on-one so it's like is a difficult
one how about I'll just pay you and
they'll alright cool and then I'll pay
them upfront for six months and then I
won't go it's a hard one I'm the same
man I'm the same do little bits but no
biggest thing is having putting time
aside to have gratitude
I think being grateful is the biggest
asset yeah I'd agree with that if you're
an ungrateful person you even if you're
rich financially and you have a good
business and stuff you just stink
entitled ungrateful proud arrogant and
there's a fine line between confidence
and arrogance and people sometimes I
think mission just and me is arrogant
but I think arrogance and entitlement
stinks
and no one self-made Arnold
Schwarzenegger said this I went when we
had a like a VIP donor thing he said
this because he's he is the definition
of what people mean when they say
self-made literally came from nothing no
money had lots of things against them
mid-america on his own when America on
his own couldn't speak the language very
well you know literally nothing going
for him just even his name that was a
big thing yeah sure like it's hard to
say yeah so you know literally you
wouldn't back that horse if you're if
you're a gambling man you wouldn't put
money on he was going to be the Governor
of California one of the most famous and
respected Hollywood movie stars
extremely wealthy property portfolio if
that property was what I did financially
free before he proceeded Hollywood you
know so he is the definition of what
people say self-made first thing he'll
say when you talk to him about how he's
done what he's done since then no one's
self made I'm here because of the people
that supported me believed in made the
mental the trainers which I just think
he's a fabulous attitude yeah and I'll
try I try and imitate that a little bit
I don't think I'm as humble as Arnold
but did you think you should be more
humble mate should always be more humble
you can never be too humble and it's a
good thing sometimes people think I'm
the bomb the boss on the oh no I can't
be seen cleaning floors and stuff it's
not it's not a good look it's against my
brand it's a bad positioning it's really
not it's really not because if you won't
pick up the if you won't stack the
chairs when you've got an event if you
won't and it's not to say okay there's
this value in your time
it's good to value time but if you're
not prepared to do that ever if you're
just like I wouldn't do that principle
is beneath me then don't expect anyone
else to do that so I think I think I
think it's born yeah I agree
so what would you say right now biggest
new lessons that you've had or anything
going on your life that's interesting
that you think will be a value to anyone
okay you know when you do something last
minute and you're forced to suddenly do
it at the last minute I can very much
relate to that yes right I am at the
moment recently been interviewing some
really cool people like I mean tomorrow
I'm interviewing James Caan should we
really call when I've been in to do some
really cool people like dr. John
Demartini yeah and I've been interviewed
by some really cool people
Slate's now but when you interview
someone you've got a research than
beforehand and I think studying some of
these guys like I've just read James
Caan's autobiography I might have read
it years ago or so half ready to commit
almost different you read it when you're
meeting them know you take you Sookie
Tokyo you sat down with someone talking
about property in different ins but also
interviewing them for the YouTube
channel forces you to really research
them deep as deep as you can and get
questions and write good and I've
learned so much doing that I've learnt
so much doing that I've just as I've
just read James Caan's I've read is it
biography but I also read I've read one
of his books called stew how to start a
business in seven days we just okay
spoke if it was amazing like I was
reading I was just thinking man and I
think if I'd have read the book a year
ago I don't think you would have the
same impact and sometimes I'll reread
books and it'll be like I've read a
completely different book yeah because
I'm a different season in my life
so what we're talking about one of the
big things I think it's studying
successful people and studying them
again and again and again so could you
relate different things so James Caan
talks about his whole life as an
entrepreneur he tooks right from a
teenager up until like when he wrote the
book and you'd normally all relate most
of the bit where he's talking about
successful business but now taking
things to a whole new level and some of
the growing pains and the staff and
finding good people and I'm like that's
where I am so in that section of the
book I'm like wow I'm really reading and
I'm living it probably a couple years
ago for the reddit I'd have read you'd
be related to when he was a teenager or
just inspired to when he's on the
mountain as a dragon so it's just I
think it's fabulous studying successful
people and also as well remembering that
there's not necessarily always a right
and a wrong way to do business
sometimes okay i I very much agree with
that I remember when the first few
business books of stuff I read it was
like ah you do it this way
you do it that way and then when you
start reading over books it's like oh
hold on who's right yeah who's right one
of them got me right yeah and because at
school when you it's black and white
isn't it yes you read it you read you
know you do maths paper it's this or
that you read the newspaper that they're
looking for this answer yes so what
works for someone else might not work
for you
yeah here's the thing be a student of
many and a follower of none so like I
even say this is where my students see
the corn students
I don't want followers I want students
I'll be able to learn from me and grow
from me but not just me and find other
people and have someone to to train you
physically or relationally or different
types of business and aspects and it's
not about who's right or who's wrong
it's about like okay you could read Lord
Sugar's blog Rafi you could read Richard
Branson's Bartra finger or who's right
well now some of them are right normally
what I do is I look at who's richer and
then I've said that person is right but
some sort and that is the day's not a
bad rule of thumb sometimes it depends
if you're wanting to learn about finance
and business who's richer because it's
like and I say mr. monster health who's
healthier right when you went when you
out earn me then fine you can argue but
listen man because I get people trying
to argue with me about how to run a
business or how to invest in property or
whatever and they're not doing it right
you watched three shows of The
Apprentice and now you try to tell me
how to run my business you telling me
how to invest in my I had to run how to
do the castle and how to renovate and
how I'm doing it all wrong when you've
done what oh you refurbed your own
kitchen you painted your mom's doorway
alright thanks for your advice man I'm
not interested
I most people are kind of it wasn't like
most people are unsuccessful because
they take advice from their neighbor and
family yeah listen I am very coachable
you know you've seen me with people like
I'm sat around a table like this you've
lured sugar
he's giving me advice I think it's
important I think it's important now do
you always learn and always reading
always I love unlike what was I like
when we sat at Grant Cardone
he's only more than money than me and in
this context right now I'm the mentee on
the learner so I'm like teach me what am
I doing wrong
how can I grow yeah Wow you very much
I'm very coachable but then sometimes
and I won't shoot people down but you
got to if I listen to every piece of
advice you know and most people's advice
if you you got to look at them so if
someone says to you oh don't do that
whiskey okay all of you done okay you're
working in a job you don't like you've
got a miserable marriage like no no
offense I don't want to take advice from
you and you wouldn't you don't even have
to say that you can just think it and
firstly thank you for sharing and walk
on someone said to me of like a little
bit like that on one of the saw I saw
someone did a video saying no money down
deals I'm not possible yeah and they
were like that and saw a very
interesting point of view not what
Samuel lead says somewhere else where
Islander said yeah but does this guy in
his own castle it's like so he's like
saying oh I know me downs not possible
but like he's not successful himself so
for him you know they're probably not
they're not possible for him you're
right anyone that says something's not
possible is speaking from poverty a
poverty mindset because everything is
possible
you know like within again within reason
you can take things out of context but
like I am talking about what not
possible why not find solutions for what
is possible mmm you know so anyone the
saying you can't do that that's not
possible that's risky that's that's for
me that's coming from a broke mindset
I'd rather hmm the way you're going
about doing that isn't gonna work it's
possible but let me show you the better
route that all listen to but someone
just as you can't do it it's just it's
just to me it's boring can I interest it
I've been told that all my life you know
it's a lot when people tell you that you
can't or even intended to do this but a
difference not like when people say it's
all right for you you're happy now
because you're 20 years old
and you're single and that's why you're
so happy enough so much energy wait
until you are in a relationship
everything changes and then you get in a
relationship and life still great and
you still happy you still got loads of
energy wait five years oh you went to
your marriage you wait and tell you how
kids are you wait till you have your
second kid you wait until the end it's
like life life is still fantastic
actually are you just prophesying your
life on
me I think that's probably what this is
about because you keep saying wait until
wait until wait until wait until well
what's next oh wait until they leave
home then you will be depressed stop
waiting for me to be depressed stop
waiting for me to fail and you become
successful and stop prophesying your
[ __ ] over my life you know that thus and
I don't listen to it no I know and I'll
shoot them now I do I've ever seen
people I remember when you were when you
were in relationship with Amanda and
people were so all wait to get married
I mean be really angry I'm a very
hardcore with them yeah and I sometimes
I'm probably up to two sensitive towards
it cuz I'm just like awesome and because
sometimes it's culture sometimes it's
just people say things they don't mean
it's because it's the cool thing to say
wait until this age I know and then
they're like whoa he took that bad on me
tell me you might not remember but you
told me interesting story about someone
you went for a business meal yeah I
remember what I said up do you remember
the story yes yes if we can't think I
can't think I there's a similar thing
where someone was prophesied nasty stuff
overnight you know in a cultural
culturally acceptable way because in
England it's okay to be miserable but
it's expected knowing about the weather
moan about the government moan about
sense or thing yeah just interested no
no no negativity no negativity and
that's not and people say you know I
just you know no but you need to be a
realist listen when I need to be
pessimistic I'm pessimistic when I'm
gonna do in a day I'll look at the worst
case of the deal okay so that that's
just called been doing good due
diligence and risk assessing things mmm
but in my life generally Oh big picture
stuff of doom and gloom and I know I
can't stand it no I'm a dick I'm
addicted to success I'm addicted to
positivity and I'm completely allergic
to negativity some people are allergic
to money and they'll sabotage it what I
was on the opposite our Sabbath sergeant
negativity and I'm addicted to getting
more money and more successful helping
more people I groove everything you said
well put so talking about growing and
learning what's what right now you know
you mentioned earlier about how
you like art you know you don't choose
not to swear for example if you learn it
you do to sorry not swear but until I
did that was an example but yeah but
what right now in your life maybe since
moving to London are you trying to
implement in the business when your
personal life in order to grow and
improve ah man I don't know man it's a
really good question I guess so you be
interesting your take on this because
you probably know the answers about me
more than I know about me
so with the business I got it to a point
you became CEO we became business
partners we took on sericea oh we've got
some really good stuff and people like
that and all I then was like right I'm
now going to step right back and I'm
just gonna be a bit more passive and
hands-off and I'm gonna you know kind of
just focus on you know whatever and
there was it's very kind of relaxed
passive training base doing training
whoever that build marketing videos you
know going out just travel in whatever
it might be okay so I'm not saying to do
nothing I didn't know value but just not
involved in the everyday stuff and then
I think now I disagree with that a
little bit because I'm looking at some
of these guys like Lord Sugar for
instance sugar still goes to the office
and gives a hat and gets hands-on and
stuff so I replaced myself and stepped
down on a business and now I'm beginning
to step back into it a little bit why
number one I love it but number two is I
think I think it's I think yeah that's
value I think you know I think I think
that it's important that you've replaced
yourself to a point where you're not
needed you can own train and stuff for a
month I can travel it's a lot for know
it doesn't matter
however as you enjoy working it makes
sense that you're here because you can
help us grow and plan and all that sort
stuff so yeah I praying the staff like
yesterday I spend I spend a few hours
with the marketing team talking about
vision and how to stand out and like a
whole bunch of stuff and it was just so
cool I don't know they loved it as well
but and the same with some of the
training advisors customer service and I
really enjoy training the stuff being
part of it you know and I think so
that's kind of my focus at the moment
being a part of the often a part of it
helping recruit good people being around
and that's what I thought you were gonna
say when I asked a question in my MA
I was thinking honorable a lot of the
things we've been talking about this is
actually one of the things that we
learned from Robert Kiyosaki the biggest
takeaway I had when we met with Robert
Kiyosaki was if you'd asked him he'd
have someone that did that for like a
tax expert they said oh man he's just
literally just surrounded himself with
brilliant lawyers accountants tax
experts yeah developer so one of the
things that we've done is brought
someone in to help us find deals yeah
absolutely expert in commercial property
development yeah so I think I feel like
that's probably the biggest thing that
we've been working on over the last well
ever when we spoke about Robert Kiyosaki
and it was laughs stupid yeah we're at
that so I don't know expert people
around and also I think as well we used
to think very much down the lines of
create extraordinary systems and then
your average people to run those
extraordinary systems and I think we've
moved away from that a bit now I think
know you do need extraordinary people
you really do I think so and they store
their systems are fantastic but and also
I used to look at companies like
McDonald's and think this business has
got really average people serving the
chips and running it but it's just got
such good systems that's true right but
no it's it is to a point but here's what
you forget yeah that's what you see when
you go to McDonald's but the people that
really run the business the people put
I'll pull the strings and make it happen
the visionaries I bet they have got the
best marketing team the best solicitors
the best but you just don't see them
seven chips hmm so and how many decades
has it taken McDonald's to get those
systems in place where they can do that
long to be too clever you know I just
read the e-myth you know seven years ago
Martin mmm-hmm and even if it's a great
book but rather than trying to be too
clever too quick just get really good
people around you
mmm and then let the more the Google
approach and let yeah and let then
create the systems so I'm trying to give
our team more freedom to put the systems
in place and some will step up and
somewhere and that's fine but then at
least your people have the opportunity
to go far and to go you
so rather than doing everything yourself
I am the owner and the this person I'm
going to put together all the systems
and then find the people do it a lot of
entrepreneurs are control freaks aren't
they control freaks let them put
together the manuals hmm and it is hard
sometimes and and any company's gonna
have problems and that we've dropped the
ball as a company and we've messed up
and because when you give freedom to
staff sometimes they're not going to do
it as you would do it but you've got a
choice you can either be control
absolutely everything can do everything
yourself and micromanage in which case
you probably not gonna drop the ball but
you got only gonna ever be very very
small mm-hmm all grow learn give freedom
and if you want to impact more people
want to grow bigger business you need to
be able to grow you need to get people
around you you need to rely on other
people be a team and you need to let go
but still keep responsibility so let go
of having to be in control but then when
it goes good praise the staff but it
goes bad take responsibility that's a
true leader
well hey awesome stuff some real gems
Daenerys Beaton been great interview
yeah thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]